when you
find somebody's story that you want to
tell if you're a producer i think the
most important thing that you you need
to do is
is it a producer's job to gather ip
well
i i would think so i mean you know
[Laughter]
you know neil moritz uh who who is the
the master behind fast and the furious
you know
you think about how that that incredible
franchise was birthed off of an article
in the back of the metro and the la
times i think it was a metro section or
valley section about subculture of
street racing and those cars
that's what a great producer does is
they comb articles you know a lot of
lazy ones like to watch 2020 or dateline
those things usually don't get made into
movies if they do they
they only go so far
um
i find that some of the great producers
that i've been fortunate enough to know
are the ones that would give me the time
of day to at least you know talk to
it's these these these guys are on the
hunt they are constantly looking for a
needle in a haystack
you know whether it's neil moretz or
david heyman or
you know david zillon i mean they're
just constantly looking
looking and looking
for that thing that just knocks them
over
and
i think good producers don't wait for it
to come to them i think it's a
producer's job to you know we talked
about the music industry earlier what
made what made a great
record executive and it was the ones
that went to the nightclubs you know the
roxy the whiskey and the gazaris at
two o'clock
you know on a monday night and watch
that headlining band on a monday or
tuesday that's that's where bands like
van halen were found and you know i know
i know their history but i'm just saying
that they were signed off of a really
crappy
attended night
on the strip on a weeknight and
i think producers need to be more
proactive i think you know we we have
gotten to the point where
it's we are so used to everything being
at our fingertips we can research
everything we you know instant
gratification and i think the days you
know i mean there were i remember when
when i knew neil moritz years ago long
before we did gridiron gang together
i never saw neil without scripts you
know i mean every time you saw neil he
had scripts he was always reading
that guy was just constantly he was a
sponge for content
and you know it paid off look at the
career he's had i mean the guy's doing
everything
and
it's about finding those you know those
books that nobody
has the rights to that you that you see
wow this can this this ip can change the
world and you know i'd be careful
um
you know
if if it's successful it's probably
owned but i think there are some gems
out there that are waiting to be found
that you know it's always nice when a
producer especially somebody younger
newer or somebody who may be more green
or
not have the deep pockets that some of
these these folks have to be able to
find something and create it and and get
it made
but i i think it's it's a producer's job
that's if you're going to produ you know
there's two kinds of producers there's
they're the ones that find the ip raise
the money get the distribution and the
stars attached and then there's the
producers that are you know more the
line producers that are on the film that
are
you know hiring the crew and getting the
locations and getting all the vendors
and gear and
everything done
but
you know when you talk about a producer
who is going to do the suit side of the
job
uh if you will
um
i think it's just so important to just
be a sponge be open to
anything and everything you just never
know where you're going to find that
that that thing
you know
and how would one know if
the rights are owned whether it's life
story rights or there's actually a
script or yeah you know in
acquiring property is
several different ways you can do it i
mean if one of the one of the biggest
passion pieces i have that i swear i'm
going to get made before i die
is the kelly sutton story i mean here's
a woman who held
the speed record at daytona who's living
with multiple sclerosis i mean she was
supposed to die when she was eight years
old she's cheated death seven times i
think she's been a widow three times
over
her story is unbelievable
i was shooting a documentary in in
wyoming in montana when the whole world
was on fire up there back in like a 102
and i was sitting in a holiday inn and
we were we were basically being kept in
a hotel because of the fire danger
and i
had nothing to do the tvs were out the
electricity was out and i went to the
lobby of the hotel and i found this
sports illustrated and there was a tiny
little sub article you know you could
read through the magazines and they've
sometimes got a little sub something on
the side and
it said she'll she'll stop at nothing
that was the name of the article and it
was about kelly girl sutton
and
it was
three paragraphs from a paragraph long
it was the most incredible piece i'd
ever read
i got home i reached out to the family
to nascar i found her you know the
internet wasn't as amazing back then was
able to find her talk to her parents got
in touch with kelly flew out to a race
watched her race a nascar event
and
such a wonderful human being
one of the one of the most delightful
business relationships i've had you know
i i feel like
we've failed we haven't gotten the
filmmade yet we came very close a couple
times
um had a green light at a network that
an agent was good enough to ruin agents
are good at that
um
but that
when you
find somebody's story that you want to
tell if you're a producer i think the
most important thing that you you need
to do is
is is be humble you know a lot of people
in our industry go to people with hype
and pomp and circumstance with all the
promises you know and well look when
somebody's story is breaking news like
the little girl that fell into well 30
years ago
every studio in hollywood's going to try
to get that you know so
step aside you're not getting those
rights chances are um
but
you know if you find something that you
like as an article in the back of a
three-year-old sports illustrated or you
see a piece on tv or you caught a news
segment
you know i always say reach out as
humble as possible and just say look i i
fell in love with your story i want to
tell your story and i want to see it's
told in a way that you can be proud of
that will represent you and your family
um and just go in with with a servant's
heart
i've been fortunate to to own a lot of
intellectual properties of life rights
you know whether it was the rick and
dicky hoyt story or you know
the great iron gang that's one
that we had
it's just it's about
being kind it's about being gentle it's
not about selling the hype you know a
lot of people go into those things not
realizing that the people that they're
approaching are not hollywood people
so
they're very off put by our energy often
you know whether we call it passion or
pomp and circumstance or just a bunch of
i don't know but
we tend to go in
on ten
a lot of these people have often just
gone through a pretty dramatic situation
in their life or a pretty
extraordinary situation they're being
courted by all sorts of people or
getting all sorts of press that they're
not used to
and i think you know it's important to
remember that these people are not of
our world
in business
there are ways to
try to penetrate their
their their world and not be
you know intrusive
great way to get ip though
is to scour articles oh articles
datelines you know 2020s
you get to a point that where a lot of
executives will start hearing things and
they'll say it sounds like a dateline it
sounds like a 20 20 story you know
things are probably better served there
but there are some remarkable stories
that come out of them there really are i
mean i fell in love with it the bruce
murakami story i don't think everybody
remembers that where
poor gentleman was you know his his wife
and two children got into a minivan and
went to the store and they were they
were t-boned by a street racer killed
the wife and two kids
and um
the kid was going to go to prison and
bruce stepped in and asked for mercy
from the court
it was the ultimate story of of
compassion and trying to change a life
instead of sending a 16 year old kid to
prison for 10 years
i'm going to take this kid under my wing
i'm going to
and i i saw it on dateline or 2020 like
20 years ago
bruce flew out met with him and and um i
really liked bruce a lot but he was also
being courted by everybody else
film ended up getting made i think with
dean kane and lifetime or something but
it was it was one of those things you
knew it was going to get made
you know
is interesting but uh you know yeah it's
about
you're basically pitching you
as a filmmaker you know we talk about
writers going into the roman pitching
and
you may not be a writer if you're a
producer but you have to meet the family
or the survivors
people that have gone through some
extraordinary circumstances and try to
pitch them on feeling comfortable with
you i mean you're selling them on you
and your game plan and your tone and
temperament
when did you realize you had to
transition away from screenwriting i was
horrible at it
i mean you know
it wasn't i just you know
i i i worked as a screenwriter for a
number of years i was very fortunate
um i was more passionate about being on
set and working with people i'm a people
person at the end of the day it's one of
my many faults
and when you're a writer you're you're
isolated you're locked up and you're
that way too as an editor which i still
get stuck doing
but
it's it's more interaction um
you know but
i just i just got to the point you know
i as i got older and realized where my
passions were and my energies were and
my strengths and weaknesses were
writing just i started working with you
know
people you know i work a lot with cj
wally i just when i read his work it
made me want to make movies again i was
i was done you know
i was ready to phone you know be done
do the book go teach i had a teaching
opportunity at a university to come in
and
i read a script that cj wrote and i said
this guy makes me want to
keep making movies
and i realized that this this guy can
tell the stories that the kind of
stories i want to tell and we
collaborated really well together
and you know it's exciting when you read
somebody's work that inspires you to
keep going because i was you know i was
tired i had been beating a bag a long
time and
kind of thought you know
i've i've been very fortunate i've been
very blessed i made my mark good bad or
different i made a mark may have been a
stain in some people's eyes but i made
one
and i wanted to teach and inspire and
encourage the next generation and and i
just i just felt that the amount of time
it took to write
and it wasn't allowing me to make a film
a year or two films a year the way i
wanted to
and it's great to work with somebody who
understands and gets me knows how to
write for schedule and budget
we want to tell the same stories
i don't need to do that anymore
what's it like having
written and developed your own work now
hiring writers or partnering with other
writers to tell those stories
well you know it's it's nice to be able
to
focus
on on certain things and not spread out
too thin you know write produce direct
edit
get the financing all that stuff it's it
really is it's a taxing business i mean
this business will eat you up even if
you have one job
and you know spending the years writing
and developing something and trying to
get it financed and get it produced
it takes a lot of time and and i kind of
go back to having the ability to work
with somebody who we we both want to
tell the same stories we both want to
make
fun action comedy action thriller female
driven let the guys sit in in the
passenger seat let the girls drive
make these fun films
and
we we both
love the same kind of movies we're both
inspired by the same kind of movies you
know going back to like the old hal
needham films you know dirt movies and
you know
fast cars you know race against time
cannonball run
smoking a bandit you know
and it's just it's easy it's it's almost
like we don't it's like hey we're going
to line up to do another one
what do you think about this
interesting okay what if we did that
it's a very
simple process that the long part of it
is you know cj in our situation cj will
just go through the whole breakdown and
develop development notes and you know
basically block it out
you know and then once that's done the
scripts come very fast it's a very fast
process like we did double threat that
was created in
mid-september we were shooting that by
october 15th i mean we had a script in
six days you know we all knew the story
we wanted to tell it was just about
going out and rolling a dice during
covet and doing it
and as i said earlier it was the most
fun i've ever had making a movie
and i hope i hope that translates on the
screen we had a lot of fun